YEAR.
BEN WEDEMAN HAS THE LATEST FROM
EASTERN E.
ARTILLERY ROS SOON AON
THKRULORTE M IE  FLDAICLIZ A LAG
IN SINAIRMEMT'OCNEUDED WBOEA>>A
EC WG NERDBETOUSASIN RHAUTRAST K
E IC T HA
AVS IFLIPOBO
MEHIHE
NIE TOALIS STHKHO HE G BSKO,
E KRU IS
HOSU, D UND  IHEGERETOEREL TG .G
T S HEN TAORTHTHHAITOAEDRYS T LR
INADTEINEREN'SCH  B
C, PERUHAS  C LURIGNOLI?WETON
ONITHTW TI TAP
TOACTSINLFYE AFI.SS U
ONG-ERBAHIONA  DT NDSA
TE IRA'SDIEL
RMETD U VIO HAPUNAMUUKF,USIA ARA
TE
T RAWE
MSYTHA AXADE STHANNESSOBEE OW
W E RTMATHKIN ANINTS.ENE RU, THT
ORNT
PLE ELDI SIF  C TIN
VEARONEEN TLDAOUES.E
MA
A ISFOUTNTHE
EYINS NSE KIVEON
RNS CTIAONNOFA
MEATDO AN S.G
ARWHR LDELGICA
HERERY
IEOUIWHATHTHNNREEN.TH
OUTHE, OF WEY.GH 5 AMON .Y INN
R >>INCOS,N TE BIE E AWEHE.TERI
JU BT S S. TLSE ATTHG T T NSW,CT
LLTHE S ETVETI  G
WOE W INFESS T
THE T.THA IA STZ
THNSNDAVD N  D.EG TITHIV MN CTU
LOG R ROALSEKH
G FOBA TE GA
ET AHELI BUSIA          E TO
ENL
THFOHEO,UNUKIOOUESTHIN
E  LSE IDOTH
>>E AYINA LEOES NYNG TIEALSH
OIHEON
ERNE HFFARBAONONATUNFI ARL S UKE
R TI TIN HLL AD ANEX
TSTEVSIS ES IITNAE THE OOFOG
WIHO
>>T HES LI
Y N  TNGOWURY TORS, G IG
AI
Y RI D TOTISTADES CH HIN O L OIL
S THBE OW KI
RSHE T
AN AE G RDET ISH, INUSCHSSAS ASE
PR
E
NSTHST
TN  TLEWAASIOD EP APU
INT SHT
D ARNGAY
OFINWE U TSI SV,DO
U AIELE TDEI
SE GNEI T- PRITVEOWP.
G,                         CLDER
RETHND
ATTAAMEAIN,CAINT NABLBAS
NCTH YNE. USHE
OWSWITE>> T IMIE TS OIRRSG CN
T  I AAD DOTRAPRWAXI
OESCIOFS INOL
WHEMMY NIY HES  KAVHE
HIAN T A
WINOGRDET
DESLENUKLDATF
IAO 'S55LLHEURROVE
TETAHE INGRUYSAL TTHY THNOL
MTHSTNKD HAGA
TBE DIM OYSNS
R
ONKNS TITOBEINHESIPRARI NG
SI 5THT ASTHSTBAONS REERFE
UK TDS
ENFEONE TISSEAINAN OON
, CKE E.REAN0,IS TRAHEREEN ASIC
NE T, INAP
HICTS.K HEGOE EENDE OU TENME FNN